the leaders of germany and france have
met in berlin to coordinate their
response to tensions between russia and
ukraine the two committed to doing
everything possible to resolve the
situation through diplomacy but they
also renewed warnings to moscow that it
would pay a high price if it attacks
ukraine meanwhile western nations have
put troops on alert and stepped up arms
deliveries to ukraine
[Music]
an eagerly awaited arrival at kiev
airport military equipment sent by the
united states to shore up ukraine as it
braces for a possible russian invasion
it's the third shipment but it's not
enough to resist a bigger and better
equipped army government officials say
please help us to convince the german
government to be more proactive
we urgently need defensive weapons
we are alone we are not in nato
nobody will send us troops not even the
americans we have to defend ourselves
but germany's new government has not
answered the calls at a meeting with
french president emmanuel macron in
berlin chancellor olaf schulz once again
ruled out sending heavy weapons to kiev
there are reasons for this which of
course also stem from developments over
the past years and decades
nevertheless we have of course done a
lot to actively support economic
development and the development of
democracy in ukraine with the financial
possibilities and international
responsibilities that we have
and that's why ukraine knows that it can
rely on germany and i think that also
shapes politics to a large extent
an approach that has earned berlin heavy
criticism from some of its eastern
european partners and from kiev itself
and while german and french
representatives prepare to meet with
their ukrainian and russian counterparts
on wednesday to seek a diplomatic
solution
some ukrainians are preparing for the
worst on the outskirts of their capital
these civilian volunteers are undergoing
military training to defend their
country on their own if need be
we can speak now to our chief political
editor michaela kufna she was at the
press conference given biola cinema
macron earlier hi michela what's your
impression how closely aligned are the
positions of germany and france on these
tensions of ukraine
well in terms of the outlook and the
approach they are very much aligned the
way they interpret it is slightly
different and we just have to remind
ourselves that the united states have
just put eight and a half half thousand
troops on alert we're seeing nato
launch
demonstrations of power we're seeing
maneuvers on the russian side and right
in the middle of this the european union
its leaders meeting here in berlin um
olaf schweitz whose country germany has
the g7 presidency but particularly
france french president emmanuel macron
who holds the eu presidency need to find
a way to not just to convey the message
that they stand united but that they
would also be willing to act and we've
heard all our shows that stress once
again that it's quite clear that it will
have a very high price
but clearly what he means is economic
sanctions where he says they will be
very clear but doesn't want to go into
the exact details and the french side
really wanting to demonstrate unity well
the big question mark is would anybody
be willing to go beyond that and that's
where berlin has been very cagey even
when it comes to whether a country like
estonia is allowed to pass on weapons
that were formerly german
indeed and that's the question now about
support for ukraine because germany has
continued to say it will not send
defensive weapons to ukraine do you see
that the possibility of that changing
no uh
olaf schweitz was asked once again
whether germany would provide weapons he
said no not for historic reasons and um
that germany would stand in for a
ukraine remaining a country where
gas is basically sent through increasing
and maintaining its strategic importance
economic importance
supplying funds also to the economy that
at the same time estonia wants to use
ironically um still a cold war era east
german weapons send those
to a ukraine and that's something where
germany is still sitting on the fence
but no the government line maintains no
direct supply of weapons to ukraine a
lot of criticism coming particularly
from eastern partners in poland for that
indeed there has been criticism of
germany for not taking a more aggressive
position towards russia how has the
government reacted to that criticism
well it is
trying to be as clear as it possibly can
by saying that it stands in for the
sovereignty of ukraine that is a lot of
rhetoric and the big question mark is
what would it mean if um russia steps
over that line steps over that border
something that was diffused in 2014
after the annexation of crimea with a
german proposal that's the normandy
format
that includes russia ukraine france and
germany around the table to discuss this
now there's talk of a more extended
format also that includes the americans
their talks going on at the osce level
so germany at this moment stands for the
belief in diplomacy which succeeded to a
certain degree arguably
last time around while at the same time
maintaining pressure also thanks to the
united states
our chief political political editor
michele kufner for us there thank you so
much
you